We are thrilled to have,
uh,
two folks really intimately involved
obviously by his face on the screen.
Um,
with Richard Link ladders film boyhood.
Uh, Matt Linkous is an
accomplished photographer,
local here to Austin and in 2002 he was
asked to take annual photographs of the
cast of boyhood to capture them throughout
the film process and he just released
his book boyhood 12 years of film
featuring his right his photos and some
writings from the cast and his time.
And then joining Matt
today is Ellar Coltrane,
so also an Austinite and a
star of the movie boyhood.
We're so lucky to have them both as their
crazy schedules on the award circuit
have kept them pretty busy
over the fast few weeks.
So we're excited they could
stop here with us today.
They were nominated for six academy
awards and they just won several Golden
Globes. Something that I think all
of us here in Austin are pretty,
pretty proud of.
So leading the conversation with Matt
and Ellora today is Chilay Nafis who's
director of programming at
the Austin film society.
Thanks so much for coming and without
further delay. Here are the guys.
I'm curious how many of you have seen,
boy,
if you haven't lie please.
Okay, no that's great.
I think then you're going to really
enjoy this and learn a lot. Um,
all of us have seen probably countless
films in which a main character grows up.
Often that character is played by a
person at six one at 12 one at 18 three
different actors,
but we're trying that particular character
and we've gotten accustomed to that.
What Richard Linklater has
done is completely unique,
taking Ellar Coltrane and filming him,
others over a 12 year period,
portions of each year.
So we literally see her grow up on state,
on screen.
So when he came through the door,
I didn't even recognize him today.
He continues to evolve.
So let's just start with a
question you're always asked.
How did you get involved with the project?
Richard is actually said that he thought
you had a very theorial mind and he was
fascinated with how you thought as a
young child. So tell us how that happened.
If I had to guess,
he saw a like mind that's a lot of,
I mean Richard has a really
hands on casting process and
no,
um,
he's much more interested in kind of
getting to know people than he is and like
how well you can memorize a
page and a half of dialogue. Um,
and so that's kind of what, you
know, I had been auditioning a lot.
I did a lot of theater when I was really
little and had gotten a with the talent
agency in town. Um, I was like five,
I guess I had one small part in a movie
called Lone Star State of mind that was
filmed here in when I was six. I got
the audition with Richard in that end.
It was very just, I mean I think they
were probably six or seven callbacks,
but he didn't have a script
for me to read or anything.
So it was just kind of a
conversation. Um, you know,
I think he had me bring in art that
I had made and talked to my parents
obviously, and we just kind of
bonded for a couple of weeks and,
and that's,
you know,
kind of everyone on the set is that's
kind of his relationship, you know,
it's very kind of about being friends
and being able to collaborate together
first before anything else.
Taking
courage you as soon cause they were
going to be part of this for 12 years.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I,
you know, I think they,
my parents have always kind of struck
a good balance of supporting me but not
being like the dreaded stage parents that
are trying to live vicariously through
their child. So they
were definitely, I mean,
they love Richard's work and so
they were definitely excited. Um,
but also, you know, I, it was
definitely a long decision.
Does it is a great commitment
and they didn't want him.
No one wanted to push me into it.
So,
uh,
Matt came in at year two,
photographing on the south,
taking portraits and all that. Tell
us how that came to be. Sister,
Kathleen and Sutherland was the producer
and actually production coordinator on
the first year, second year. And
then she hired me. I'll do stills.
And early on I saw an
opportunity to do portraits,
which is one of my favorite things
to do, portraits of people. Um,
I do still once a year maybe
on a film or commercial.
So to have that opportunity present
itself and know that I was going to,
as long as Kathleen was on the movie,
I would be on his nepotism
is alive and well here. Um,
so yeah, so when I took the opportunity
to, to make these portraits,
this is actually one of the
first portraits I made, um,
was actually a Eller and I'm
just very simple, simplistic, um,
black and white on black background.
And um,
I just wanted to continue that every
year we're going to discuss the portraits
in greater detail in a
little while. Um, Eller,
there's a tendency for a lot of viewers
to almost think this is your life in one
way or another. Uh, so just
to, I have several questions.
Tried to distinguish our,
to show where there was some overlap
between you and the character mason.
It's a narrative film,
not a documentary,
but I think at times there must
have been elements of you, um,
the open,
the film opens with you looking at
the sky daydreaming where you a
daydreamer as a child. Absolutely. Good.
That's why you got,
there's this,
there's this interview from late year
one or two I think that we unearthed that
is probably mine. Maybe it maybe is
on the DVD, I don't know. But um,
and it,
when it opens there's a
good like 30 seconds where I
maybe I didn't know we were
filming and I'm just kind of like
muttering to myself and just like looking
around and just kind of like, and then
he's like Eller and I'm like, oh hey.
My niece stared out the window for 12
years of public school and she's an artist
also. So, um, your character,
mason is very interested in
animals in nature. Is that
true view? Yes. Absolutely.
Okay, very good. We'll just go
through these quickly. We'll get,
have a check list. A, your older sister,
Samantha is played by Richard Linklater,
his daughter Laura lie. And for the
most part, you all have standards,
sibling animosity on screen in
many ways until you're older.
Do you have any siblings?
I mean, I have a nine year old sister, so
it's a very different relationship but,
but there'll be the Lorelei also has
younger sisters, so uh, you know,
anything that relationship formed pretty
naturally that we both kind of wanted a
sibling and we're able to sort of, you
know, obviously we didn't live together,
but we were able to sort of
fill that role and you know,
we're at each other's throats
instantly. Okay. Uh, when she's saying,
oops, I did it again, I wanted to throw
all the pillows at her and make her stop,
you know,
in lower lights defense though.
[inaudible] she wanted to stay and I
think was gentlemen prefer blondes. She's,
she's a little cooler than the
list. Correct. Alright. Uh,
Patricia Arquette,
you're fell model where you,
so Harry Potter to where you are Harry
Potter founders or trial and you know,
I actually wasn't,
that was one thing that I like go in,
go into the,
I never went to any of the book opening,
so it was right.
I was worried about you in that scene
and I thought there was no way that's
Eller. That is amazing
being able to do that. Okay.
Uh, Ethan Hawke is your dad tries to
get you interested in sports, football,
baseball, uh, bowling. Uh,
did you have to do about a
hundred shops to bowl so badly?
I don't think so. I think, I think
I'm just pretty bad at bowling a,
we did like a photo shoot recently where
we kind of recreated that scene and I
didn't do much better.
Um, finally on this part, um,
in the film Mason goes to 12 years of
public school and you were primarily
homeschool. Uh, how did
you feel? I think you
went to high school for a
while. I was at school. Yeah,
that's definitely the
biggest kind of difference.
Um, is that, cause I, you know, my,
my social dynamic was very
different growing up and,
and see,
I mean then I was really,
I mean that was one also one of the
most interesting parts of, you know,
having this sort of parallel,
you know, story tracing.
My, my own life is getting to kind of go
and like pretend to be in these schools
situations, which was
very foreign to me. So,
but obviously something that all the
most of my friends were in school,
so it was always this, you know, I
was very aware of this environment,
but get him to go kind of pretend for a
couple of days was pretty interesting.
So Matt, um, after you
started with your two,
did you go to the set every day of
filming or how did you decide when to go?
Yeah,
I was the onset photographer,
so I was shooting stills of the action
of the film and then also behind the
scenes shots, which are going up
every now and again over there.
So it was basically documenting
the way the film was made.
Richard Directing Eller,
Richard Interacting with Patricia,
Laura Lion. And, uh, and Ethan
when Ethan was onset and um,
what I would do is each year I would pick
a day that I knew all the actors would
be onset.
Most of the time they were,
but sometimes it would overlap
by a day or two. And um,
I would choose a location nearby set
and make my portraits on the one day.
And once I got everybody
documented for that year,
I wouldn't necessarily do the portraits
on another day of shooting that
particular year. Does that make sense?
Everything you're saying makes sense. Uh,
how, how do you manage to be almost
invisible as a still photographer on set?
How do you manage to be almost
invisible, not obtrusive and all? Well,
you have to get a good relationship with
the first lady who's leading all the
action,
which has vents and then also with the
other cameraman and the acs that work on
the camera assistant camera because
you need to be right next to the camera
getting similar shots.
But sometimes I would float around and,
and just Eller got comfortable with
me real quick and that was great.
If I was in Patricia's
eyeline or Ethan's eyeline,
that would kind of disrupt things.
So you kind of have to do
the exactly what you said.
Try to be invisible as much
as you can and be low key.
And I'm kind of a low key person
so it wasn't too hard to do. Uh,
Rick Linklater is very famous for
the relaxed atmosphere on his saps.
Um,
did that help in some ways?
Just the set atmosphere affect
your Oh, absolutely. Yeah.
I've worked on sets where the
director is not very nice like that.
Like Rick and Rick has, um, puts
everybody at ease on the, on the set.
I've never heard him raise his
voice wants, um, literally. And um,
Tyler might happen, you know, back when
rehearsals or something, I don't know,
but uh,
no,
Rick is very easy going and it makes else
at ease and everybody just does their
work and everybody's professional and
everybody knows that they have all have a
job to do and that's what makes
it come together cohesively.
And that's what makes,
that's what the beauty of this picture is,
is that we put all this effort into it
and we have this beautiful body of work.
So, uh, the photo you took of
Mason getting his buzz cut,
he's actually smiling
or laughing in the film.
He's definitely not smiling at all.
So that in a sense that it gave me a
different reading of that scene. I mean,
obviously that was Eller, whereas in
the film it's Mason reacting that way.
Uh,
why'd you decide to print that one?
For that exact reason? I wanted to show
that Eller was actually quite happy kid.
It gets haircut during that scene, or
at least I can't speak for him directly,
but he seemed to be how
we hot here. Yeah. So,
um, yeah, Eller was very happy
to have his hair cut and,
but he had to play the scene.
So I did a few takes where he was actually
smiling and that's one of the ones
that I wanted to put in the book
and having the book for sure.
And just a bit of technology. But describe
your, your equipment, your cameras,
lenses. Well. Um,
I started out shooting digital for the
production stills and behind the scenes,
which I knew it was just going
to change as far as pixels,
but that would always be the same
and what I wanted to do with,
so I use a digital camera,
a Nikon, Nikon, um,
now for the film stuff. I
originally started shooting
on film on a hostile blog,
which is this image here.
And then I had a Polaroid converted
from a land camera that shot pack film
Polaroid that had a
positive and a negative.
So I could look at the positive picture
and know that I had the negative and
then I put it in the water and wash
it later and I have a negative.
And then as time wore on, Polaroid went
out of business by about year eight,
so I didn't shoot Polaroid anymore
and had to go back to film. Um,
just straight four by five film.
And the majority of the portraits are
shot on a four by five camera. That's, um,
a wooden field camera made in
Japan called the Tacho Hora with a,
just a basic normal lens.
And really at the end of the day,
it's extremely simple camera that gets
the subject involved with the process.
And Eller himself was great.
He, he loves posing. I mean, I,
I don't know if he loved it, but he was
very amicable to me and to to do it all.
And um, and then later on Ethan would,
after a couple of years of coming back,
you can go, oh, I love that camera.
And then he'd be more inclined to spend
a little more time with me posing.
Not that I would take them, you
know, for an hour at a time.
Literally I do the shoot
about three or four minutes.
So it was a very quick process.
Okay. I'll go back to acting. Um,
how did you and Rick actually work say
in your childhood and later on as far as
action line, delivery,
body language, facial,
all of that? Um, I mean there's,
there's kind of an amazing, and you know,
a lot of what Richard does it, I mean,
I assume for most of his movies,
but definitely with this one is a lot,
or for her soul, you know, the, the,
the, the script is kind of constantly
change. And you know what I mean?
He would come, he would
come to two s, you know,
maybe a week out before shooting and
have, you know, a basic script, you know,
scenes written for that year,
but,
and then we would spend the next two week
rehearsing and rewriting bits of that
and, you know, and taking things
from our own lives. And, you know,
like you were saying, there's a lot of,
not just me, but all of us, you know,
there's a lot of, all of, you know,
Patricia and Ethan as well in the,
in the characters and just in
the, the world in general. Um,
and that rehearsal process would, was
on going, you know, into, into filming.
So there was little,
there was little difference in,
in kind of the atmosphere between
rehearsing and filming. You know,
we kind of joke that it's like a
lot of time you don't even know.
It's like suddenly you're just
rehearsing and then he's like, okay,
we got it and you're done. And, and that
is kind of how it felt, you know? So,
and that's an art, you know,
that's something that has,
when I was young I wasn't really aware of,
but that's an amazing balance to be
able to strike, to make it toward you.
You know, there's no, there's no
pressure of like, oh I'm on camera.
And especially when I was young, you know,
it changed as I got older and you know,
kind of became more confident
and aware of myself as an actor.
But when, you know, when I was
seven and then when Laurel,
I was so young, it's, that's
really valuable, you know,
to just be able to not feel pressured
and not feel on the spot, you know,
cause they think all kids like to pretend,
you know,
when it comes really naturally,
it's really easy to act
when you're seven, eight,
nine. But the problem is that a lot
of kids are pressured, you know,
you feel like you have to
perform and be cute or you know,
try to please the people around you.
And,
and Richard did a really good
job of making it, you know,
making me feel like an equal.
Then also just making me feel comfortable
so that I was able to, you know,
do what I had been doing for years
and I don't, yeah, I
mean as, I don't know,
as far as like a direct direction,
it,
it never felt like,
I mean he would say little things,
but a lot of it was just kind of born
out of the rehearsal process, you know,
so that when we were actually filming,
he didn't,
we'd already kind of knew what
he wanted, you know. Great.
Um,
was the scene with your alcoholic
Stepdad scary or fine cause that glass or
whatever brakes right in front of
you on your plate that was, um,
both they think.
Do you know what I mean?
It was definitely a
decider and there's not,
there's not a lot of like real acting
in the movie. And then, you know,
something explosive like that is certainly
your site. I know, but I think it,
I mean I'm sure, I think
it was scary too. You know,
it's the kind of thing that you kind of,
it's easy to
ignore it when you're a kid,
but looking back it's like,
it definitely was an intense
experience, but, but they also,
you know, we like Patricia
with, you know, they would all,
everybody would start kind of joking in
between tapes to sort of distract us I
guess from the gravity of the content.
Um,
since we would get together every year.
How soon ahead of filming
did you know what was going,
what the basic actions
are big for that year?
Um,
I mean generally at the end of each year,
Rick would give me some kind
of idea of like, hey, you know,
next year you're going to
go on this camping trip or
you're going to meet a girl
or, you know, or whatever.
And, and then throughout the
year. And we would, you know,
he would call me and take me to lunch
two or three times and kind of just
compare,
you know,
his whatever ideas he would have and kind
of asked me about what had been going
on in my life and, you know, see
where the two might overlap. Um,
so I generally had a pretty good idea,
you know,
I had a lot of time to kind of think
about that. Exactly. You know, what,
what Mason was doing and how I could
use my own experiences to kind of inform
that. Um, but then like I
said, the, you know, the,
a lot of times the final script,
the final dialogue wasn't printed
until the morning of the shoot,
which would be maddening for many actors.
But,
but if you're not a part of writing it,
I mean, it's, it, that's the thing that,
that's why is because we had been
rehashing it and rehearsing it for a week.
So it's,
it's not like we needed a memory.
We already knew the lines because we
were there and when he wrote them.
So it was,
you know,
it was definitely constantly
evolving but also very long.
You know, law enforcement
was a very longterm kind of
process for each, you know,
15 minutes.
We had a whole year to kind of rehash it
and figure out exactly the right tone.
Matt, going to your portraits
or four by five portraits,
which are really stunningly beautiful.
What was your method of,
did you direct that?
People are what?
Mostly I would just kind of have them
in character in front of my background,
just looking directly at the camera
and if you've ever seen a four by five
camera, it's a, it's a slow
process to say the least.
It's the old camera where you have to
put a hood on and look underneath on the
ground glass and focus.
So I would have elder stand there or
Patricia or whomever and I would say,
okay, hold on, let me get focused. They
would just kind of, you know, look at,
you know, look at the camera.
I'd say, okay, hold still,
I'm going to drop the film.
They're still looking still.
W I think what's captivating a lot of
these is that they really have an intense
look right into the camera.
As far as directing them.
I didn't do much direction.
Patricia's of wonderful professionals,
she didn't need any direction. I,
I would say maybe on after I did a
couple of frames of just a straight
expression, I would say let's
do one a little friendlier.
She might let us a little smile in there.
Lro I would do the same. Eller would,
you know,
we would go through a range of emotions
and expressions and mostly it was get
the,
the kind of the serious ones out of,
out of the way first and
then go into whatever,
you know, hanging out, whatever.
Looking at camera. Pretty simple.
I need to get through to teach me
how to smile for the camera. It's,
it's easy to do that in real life.
Uh,
so if you were doing a lot of
these three or four minutes,
what is your shooting ratio?
It's not very high.
I think you mean the number
of shots that you're taking?
The final choice.
So the for the fall
by five film,
so there's two sheets on a back,
you turn it over and it's quite simple.
But for Ela I would probably do,
you know, for holders, eight sheets,
eight shots and then I would do all the
digital shots cause I'm also having to
be wary of their time away from set.
So,
and placate when they want to actually
do the pictures. Like, you know,
some of them were a little more
reluctant on having their pictures taken.
Eller was never that way.
Um,
Patricia wouldn't want to spend more than
five minutes just because she wants to
do other things. Um, Ethan was okay. He,
he'd loved doing them and
Lorelei was fine as well. Um,
and I'm not trying to say Patricia was
doing anything unprofessional. She was,
she just wanted to get it done and out
of the way. She didn't want to linger.
Like Ellery she Eller is interested
in the photographic process.
So that was, you know, that was
nice to see and made my job easier.
So have you been tempted to
do any time lapse photos?
Showing them age very quickly?
Um, I did a very brief, I'm
not very good at video editing,
but I did a very brief little 32nd snip
of all of these shots before we had the
book before,
right as the film was releasing.
And I sent it to Rick and
Kathleen and showed it to the,
actually I sent it to other as
well. And it's just like, uh,
just that same thing that you've seen
on some of the programs that they show
before these guys go on
and do their interviews.
And I think it's fascinating to watch. The
face has changed for sure. Um, I'm just,
I don't, I'm not very good
at it. So, interesting.
Um,
discussing the improvisation in acting,
at what point did you and
Rick start feeling free
enough for you to improvise in
certain scenes and what
words some of those scenes?
It was never really, I mean,
there was definitely like,
I mean there was definitely an element
of improvisation to it because,
because of the fact that the district was
constantly changing and, and you know,
a lot of times we would be improvising
up until, you know, the morning
of the morning of the shoot.
But when we went on camera,
we definitely always had a
script that we follow it with.
The one exception of the star wars scene,
when Ethan and I are sitting at the
campfire deaking added deeding out about
star wars,
that there's about 45 minutes of that.
I think today for day like 45.
I mean there's a 45 seconds in the movie,
but there's another half hour probably
of just us talking about star wars.
I don't know. But, um, but yeah, I
mean that's a common misconception.
I think we achieved a lot of realism,
just threw a lot of improv
improvisation just leading up to the,
you know, leading up to
the, um, to the shoots.
So there's a lot of it is our own words,
but you know, but it was always scripted.
Um,
the transition to teenager,
I love the scene in which you're
asking your dad are there,
there's no magic in the world,
really, like elves and stuff.
Had you already reached that point
in your life or was that a terrible
revelation?
I don't think my parents,
but I think the way Santa Claus
was presented to me was as a myth.
So, yeah, I mean, I definitely
believe in magic, but not,
not that kind.
Great. Um, when you're
at a party with a girl,
you tell her how you're unhappy
with people trying to control you,
which are a teenager, nothing
surprising about that. Uh,
how does that marry you at that time?
Um, I mean, that was one of the first
pieces of dialogue that I just wrote.
So is they're just actively,
I mean,
Richard had come to me the
previous year and said, you know,
the next time you're alone with a girl
for the first time to take notes and
like, um, so that,
it's definitely my own,
uh,
pseudo philosophy from 17.
Okay.
Great.
Good year for that to happen.
That takes care of the next
question about emotional trauma. Uh,
let's see, uh, by the end, you break
free, you go to, I can sit Saul,
Ross state university and Alpine,
and then you go to big band,
uh, is a perfect place for your
photography and love of nature and all.
Um, how well do you relate to
Mason's decision to do that?
Um, I mean, I, I love that place.
I love that desert. It
definitely, I mean, I, I stayed,
I've spent a lot of time out there,
you know, it just in Big Ben, but I,
after we shot everybody else went home
and I stayed for another week or two. Um,
it's really special out there and I mean,
photography isn't as big a part of my
life as it was. I mean, that's, you know,
that's an why mason is a photographer's
because I was really interested in it
kind of as a result of, you
know, following Matt around
on the set and, you know,
looking at all these cool toys.
Um,
but that's, you know, but I
definitely, I definitely do.
I relate with the need to get
far away from home and the,
you know, the desert, um,
definitely calls to me.
So that,
that last scene is, you
know, I've, you know,
more often I'm alone, but I've
definitely had that moment, you know,
many times in my life of just being out
there and how quiet it is and just kind
of realizing how,
you know,
how for granted I take everything.
Um, Matt, this is a big question.
How do you see the difference between
the art of cinematography and the art of
photography?
Okay.
That is a big question. I find myself,
that's hard one to answer.
I'm moving pictures versus still pictures.
It's,
Eh,
we remember things differently when we
see the moving picture as opposed to one
still frame from that
picture or that movie.
So I was lucky enough to have Eller and
the whole cast to document during the 11
years that I was on the film.
And um,
I guess I think my
documentation is impactful,
but I think the film is way more
impactful when you see the moving images.
But I think that's the beauty of the
book is that it pairs well with the film.
And you can go back after seeing the
movie and seeing everything and kind of
land on a moment and land on a picture
and remember that soft face boy and then
see the chiseled man that he is now. You
know, it's like, you know, I mean he's,
he's a movie star and it's,
it's incredible to watch
the transformation and,
and I've loved that I was able
to do that photographically.
And Richard was able to do that
cinema cinema graphically. So
did you see a younger you and or when
he was interested in photography?
Um, actually yes. There was
one scene that we filmed, um,
at Austin high in the dark room scene
where the, he's getting the lecture from,
um, Mr whatever his name
is, Burlington, Burlington.
And he has that great line,
um, which is, you know,
any dip shit can take photographs, you
know, what are you going to bring to it?
And it's,
I love that scene.
That scene was really wonderful and
powerful to me because that dark room was
the actual dark room where I first learned
how to develop film and make prints.
So I was at Austin high.
I was trying to tell her that right
before the scene and we were just having a
little moment about it. But it was,
it was fun to be there and, and that,
that was a pretty powerful moment for me.
That dark room
from the very beginning we see
the true are interested in art.
You have your graffiti symbol, which I
still can't decide when were a child,
but then you take on the name because
Joe for your bedroom wall art in general,
graffiti in particular,
what are Your Art Tris?
I
that was actually a replica of a thing
I had on my wall and mine was maybe a
little more,
a little more decipherable but
burned. Maybe not, I don't know.
But yeah,
I mean that know that that's spray paint
art was definitely a big part of my
life at that point in time.
Um,
and photography is something I,
you know, I not as, I don't John,
I don't shoot constantly the
way I did when I was younger,
but it's definitely still something
I'm very interested in and you know,
Pencil and paper drawing
and painting and I don't,
I don't really know how to play music,
but I,
there's definitely a lot of it inside
of me. So I probably will someday.
Great.
Beautiful Book that has come out.
How did this come back about?
I noticed you wrote after a few years
I looked at the images collected so far
and became excited by it all looking
forward to the final volume of work.
So when did the idea for book come out?
Well,
I,
the idea originally for me was the
black and white portraits as a portfolio
piece. It's not as a book. It was really,
I was going to have this
nice body of work. Selfishly,
I was obviously going to give Richard
and Kathleen access to it so that,
you know, IFC can use, use this. But um,
that was the original intention with the
black and whites. However, year five,
year six when I was counting
up, I've got, you know,
four thousand five thousand images.
And then by the year, by year 12,
I've got close to 18,000 images. It
was a no brainer. Early on to say,
we're going to do a book,
we have to,
we have too many images to
the cheek going on. And, um,
I think it was year nine, Ethan said,
I want to write the intro to your book.
And I was like, Oh, I have a
book. And I hadn't ever talked
to Ethan about this. So,
um,
that was my first little light bulb
moment that if Ethan's involved,
and I knew Rick and Kathleen
were kind of mulling the idea,
but if Ethan were involved in it,
would really have a lot more
chance of playing out. So, uh,
and that's what actually led into the
essays that each of the actors did was
Ethan talking about doing the intro. So
Rick has the pseudo intro, but you know,
Rick was talking about the passage of
time and then everybody kind of touches on
that. And, um,
so the book actually
officially became tangible, uh,
as an idea of just this time last year.
And really,
and it was a very much a quick,
I mean we had 12 years to make the film
and we have like two months to make the
book and was kind of a quick process.
But Dj Stout at Pentagram and Stu
Taylor did an incredible job, um,
you know,
designing it and then
ut press, I've done a remarkable job of
marketing the book and distributing it.
So,
um,
I hope that answers the question kind
of long winded and I'm really happy it's
ut press, so it's another
product of Austin. That's great.
What has been the reception to the
book so far? As far as I can tell,
I mean my 10 friends like it, so,
you know, I don't know. I'm going to,
I'm kidding it, it, I think it's
doing very well and it's, it's hard.
Books in general are a hard
business as Brady will tell you.
It's anyway, it's, it's, it's
difficult, but I think it's doing well.
I just saw that it's at Costco now.
So I mean that might be a good thing
or bad thing. I don't know, you know,
but I think a Walmart, okay,
sorry. No, draw the line.
A friend of mine at Barnes and noble
said it's selling very well too,
and it will be available here
today at a really nice discount.
So we'll mention that again in a minute.
So Eller of summing up,
uh,
many of Rick's films have to do with time
and you of course get the last line of
the film. It's always right now. Uh,
is that you as well as Rick?
Yeah, I mean in hindsight,
I think it was kind of a message from
Richard to me because I definitely,
I mean that definitely I had nothing
to do with writing any of, I mean I,
you know, in rehearsal we died, we know,
helps to kind of tweak it
and put it in them, you know,
words that I had was comfortable
saying, but, but that
definitely, I mean, that was,
he knew, he knew what he wanted
to say and it definitely is,
you know, I understand that. And feel
it in a, in a big way. And like I said,
you know, I mean, I think that Ma,
that moment that Mason's having of
kind of, you know, realizing the,
the fleeting nature of reality and,
you know,
how kind of easy it is to,
forget the importance of family
and connection and just, you know,
how quickly everything's going by and
how easy it is to miss it, you know,
and then just kind of get
wrapped up and bullshit. Um,
we were all kind of having that moment
out there, you know, I think not just me,
but everyone on the set,
you know,
we were all coming to the end of this
thing that had become so much more
meaningful to us then I think to anyone,
never aside from maybe Richard
had ever expected, you know, um,
and realizing that it was over and the,
and just kind of striving to
appreciate the last few moments of,
of the project and the last one, you
know, the last day of being together. Um,
so I got a little lost there.
But, but yeah, I definitely,
I definitely, that is, you
know, that is me in a big way.
Can you even imagine your life without
having this experience? So would you be
absolutely.
I don't know. I don't know. I
mean, I, I've, you know, I've been,
both of my parents are artists
and I've been around, you know,
projects, you know, in collaboration
my whole life. So I would, you know,
I would definitely be creating things,
but I would be a very,
in a very different way.
Had I not met Richard.
Um, do you miss being mason? Are you
ready to go on? What's your own life?
I mean, both. It's something of a relief,
but it's also incredibly bittersweet.
I mean, I just, just miss
being able to work on it, you
know, but also, but I mean,
the blessing of all of this is,
you know,
that how well the film has been received
as just that we've gotten to spend the
last year together. Um, which had, you
know, no one cared about the movie,
but it probably,
you know,
we wouldn't have a thing every weekend
that we all get together for. Um, so,
so that's been nice. But definitely,
yeah, it's bittersweet, you know, hey,
I hope we get to work together again.
Okay.
I want to open it up to the audience for
questions as or that it will lead you
to this or you know, what's kind
of your reaction. But you know,
it started off with limited release and
then, you know, it's obviously taken off.
So, um, I, I mean,
I didn't expect this a year ago.
I mean,
I think we were kind of bracing
ourselves for no one to care.
That sounds funny, but it's true.
Entirely true. I mean, you know,
for the last 12 years trying to explain
this project to people, it's like, okay,
you know, Richard Linklater, like, oh,
I've heard of him. And then it's like,
it's like 12 years and like,
it's not really about anything.
And so people didn't care, you know,
it feels like, oh, that's cool.
But it's not like, oh, I'm so excited to
see that movie. It just like, okay, well,
you know, good. Tell me about
it when it comes out. Um,
so we really, we're kind of bracing
ourselves for the, you know,
for no one to really get it or to
connect with it the way cause we needed,
we know it's really important
to us and that makes it,
you know, all the, you know,
Stereo to kind of release
it to people who, you know,
may or may not understand it. Um,
but the way people have responded,
I mean much more than,
you know,
I mean the awards and everything
that's really awesome to be recognized.
But what's more meaningful is just the
way people have responded personally and
individually,
you know,
and expressed such kind
of vulnerable emotions,
you know, about that, the,
that this movie has inspired
them to feel. And that, you know,
I think we all feel pretty
vulnerable, um, releasing, you know,
putting this out there because
it's so kind of personal to us.
But a lot of people, a lot of audiences
have really matched that vulnerability.
So that's, you know,
that's really inspiring.
I heard an interview with Laura Link
Linklater on Texas Standard and her to the
film and seeing it after the,
the whole project was complete,
was quite strong. She described
crying, watching the movie,
and I'm feeling some,
I guess how strange it was to
see different parts of herself,
um, unscreened for the public in earlier
parts of her life. I wondered what,
what your reactions were to hers
and if you relate it to it at all
before Sundance, Richard,
Dave. But we had nothing,
we hadn't seen any of the footage
until, you know, until it was done. Um,
and Richard,
Dave,
both of us DVDs and kind of very wisely
advised that we watch it by ourselves.
The first, you know,
alone the first time. Um,
and I mean, obviously I was,
I, I don't think anybody
heard from me for a few days.
It was pretty intense.
Definitely. Um, I don't know.
I cried a lot. It's hard to really
describe what it feels like. You know,
I think you spend your whole
life wondering how you're
changing from day to day,
much less over a decade.
Um,
and it's one thing to look at pictures,
but to see it like that is, you know,
mind blowing and tender.
You know what I mean?
To say painful but not
really in a negative way.
It's just a lot to take in all
at once. You know, I've seen it
like 10 or 11 times now and
it is finally getting easier.
Um,
but it's very emotional.
Definitely.
Please don't watch it
alone when you're my age.
My head might be the end of year
then between now and then, fine. I,
I'm very glad Laura light didn't succeed
in convincing her dad to have her
character dive swine flu.
There was one year she just
didn't want me to do it anymore.
I think she just didn't want to dress
up for the Harry Potter thing. Right.
Oh, hey. I was just wondering,
did you get in front of the camera
at all over the 12 years and if not,
do you regret not having
that time lapse for yourself?
Uh, actually I was asked to be an extra
in one of the scenes, couple of scenes,
none of them made the cut. So thankfully
I'm not in front of the camera. Um,
in the book, however I did, my sister
took a portrait of me, so I'm in the,
if you happen to get the book, you'll
see a portrait of me in there. But, um,
as far as getting in front of the
camera, I just did that. You're four. Um,
I was a bartender or something and Rick
gave me this great line of what's your
motivation and all this stuff.
I was just the complete extra background,
fluff and clearly not important
enough to make the cut score.
And how do you see this experience in this
job affecting your work in the future?
It's funny.
Um,
I definitely take a look at
the longevity of projects now.
Like I've been shooting photographs of
kids at a Montessori School for about
eight years and watching that same kind
of growth and watching them age and it's,
it's, it's, it's interesting, it really
plays on you when you have to have that.
And, um, thankfully Ella has
agreed to continue our project.
We shot year 13 last year in May, so
a sometime coming up, if he allows me,
I will do year 14 with him.
So.
Okay.
So the movie on the whole is kind of this
like wonderful measurement of what it
is to be human. That's that curious
probably a lot of weight, right.
For you and your professional life.
Do you feel a lot of pressure now to
keep moving forward to work on projects?
Kind of UB substance?
MMM,
and I think I would feel that regardless.
Sure.
But not, I don't, I mean almost people
kind of asked me that. It's like, oh,
how are you going to like top this?
And I don't think I need to. Um,
so in a way the pressure is off.
I guess.
It's like the first movie I was in
just won best picture. So it's like
not,
there's not much like more
did I can strive to accomplish
as far as recognition,
you know, so I don't know.
But absolutely. I mean, I,
I feel a lot of responsibility
and pressure to only be,
be a part of things that
have substance and, you know,
communicate genuine emotion. Um,
but I think I would feel that way,
you know,
even if I hadn't been a part of this.
So look for you and like Morticai
too, right? Yeah, exactly.
So you promise not to do Texas chainsaw
massacre 87. You know, I add though,
I like before,
like the year two or three of boyhood,
I auditioned for that.
The Texas chainsaw remained in,
um, very wisely. I, uh, my parents
talked me out of it. I tend to,
I wanted to do it, but, um, I
have since I've heard that that's,
that was like one of the
most hellish sets ever.
Kind of glad I wasn't party.
Um, and it has to do with a scene or
two scenes in the movie. There was, um,
uh, your mother and the movie,
um, she has an exchange with, uh,
an immigrant who's working at our
house, which tells me, you're smart,
you should go to school. And then
there's a scene later on where he's like,
thank you for that. I went to
school and I managed her all that.
I'm just wondering why, why do
you think, from your perspective,
why was that included in the film
and what was the meaning behind it?
Oh yeah.
I mean I think,
I think because she,
you know,
it's kind of is underappreciated
and mom's kind of our, you know,
and she's sort of spends the
whole movie trying to ease,
you know, ease the suffering,
I guess, of all of these men
in her life. And, you know,
it was sort of punished for it,
the whole movie.
MMM.
And I just, that's a role that
a lot of mothers fall into.
Oh.
And the, and, and to be, you know,
have better appreciation from someone
who's not trying to start a relationship
with her is powerful I think.
But I don't really know.
Do you think there's a reason? I, um,
they chose randomly to have at a Mexican
immigrant and working on our house. So,
I mean, I don't, we live in Texas,
I guess that's,
yeah.
I don't know the cause a lot of Mexican
immigrants do that kind of work and are,
you know, put in a place, you know,
by whatever pre, uh,
preconceptions of society,
you know, that they can't
rise beyond, you know,
this idea of what an
immigrant is in this country.
Um, and, but also a lot
of, a lot of people do.
A lot of people come here and start
doing work like that and you know,
make fairy, um, I dunno,
uh, successful lives for
themselves. So yeah. Thank you.
So a lot of times as you know,
little kids weren't into one thing or
another and we make decisions off those
and change those really quickly.
You know, was there ever any time,
like you kind of were questioning your
role in the movie and being a part of it
and like,
guess what kinds of sacrifices and things
had you like or what happened you got
to do that you kind of wanted
to do when you were a kid?
Or how did that kind of overlap with work
balance for slight bounce some during
the movie for so long?
With so many years.
I mean, I don't, nothing, never.
I, I never wanted, I never,
I never questioned my decision.
I mean, I, you know, I was,
I was never terribly rebellious.
I never had much of a reason to be,
I wasn't in public school,
so I didn't have that,
like inherent need to rebel against all
forms of authority. Um, they kind of,
you know, it was kind of fun to
have an obligation, you know,
something I was committed to
and, and it's in, you know,
I think you here 12 years and it sounds
like it's like taking up my whole life.
But like I've said, it was like a
week and a half each year, you know,
so it wasn't,
I don't think that ever kept me from doing
anything else, you know? I mean, yeah,
I stopped auditioning for other movies.
That's the only thing.
But auditioning just sucks.
And that's why I did that. So
Bette Davis had to audition for the movie
in the fifties and she just took our
two Oscars, put them on the
table and said nothing else.
So you're going to be able to take
some awards along with you. It's the,
it's different now they're
sending is different. Auditioning
for commercials sucks.
Yes.
During that week and a half, what would
a typical day of filming look like?
I mean,
during the week and a half,
there was it about three or four
days of actual filming and you know,
a lot of times in the morning
we would still be, you know,
working on tweaking bits of
dialog and rehearsing and
yeah.
You know, but other than that, I don't
just, I don't know, standard, I guess,
you know. Um, I think
Richard, you know, he,
we did a lot of tapes when we first
started and I think Richard maybe had,
became more confident as we went along,
so things became more kind of efficient,
I guess as the years went on.
But,
um,
I don't know. We would just shoot and,
well, like I said, you know, it was very,
like everyone has said it's
very relaxed and you know,
so it was like the rehearsal
was constantly going and
the difference between
rehearsing and shooting, you know, wasn't
that noticeable. It was just kind of
something we were all working on together.
And Matt,
what other projects do you have coming
up apart from the aforementioned shooting
of the children, if that sounds
really bad? Photographing? Yeah,
children. Um, I,
I have a lot of different projects
besides shooting, shooting up children.
Amid that comment please.
Um,
aside from my annual portrait with Eller,
um,
I do a lot of different things. I do a lot
of head shots and, um, commercial work.
I shoot food, I do interiors,
I do a lot of different things.
I'm working on movies is fun for me.
If I did it all the time,
I probably would have a little bit more
of a different outlook about movies
because it's a really long day on set.
You shoot things from three
different angles. You have moves.
Like Eller was saying about the
typical day of filming on set.
It's actually quite grueling because it's
just so boring to be perfectly honest.
Like, I mean, it's exciting being
on a movie set, don't get me wrong,
but doing it day in, day out, day in,
day out, it's, it's, it's tough work.
It's really tough. Um, so that's
why I don't do very many films.
I just do it a few, you know, one or
so a year maybe, but, and with red fun,
you know, Ellen, I hope that answers
your question about shooting.
So you mentioned right now, what is
your reaction to like a huge, you know,
spike in attention in your life and,
uh, your projects moving forward?
Yeah,
figure out what my reaction is. I
guess it's really excited. No, I mean,
I like making art and you know,
there are a lot of amazing filmmakers out
there that I'd like to work with then,
you know, I might have the
opportunity to do that now.
So that's definitely exciting.
Question for Eller.
Um,
are your memories of the film and
he experiences going through it,
it's still your memories or
do you feel that they
have been impacted by the,
by the positive reception of the world?
Like we look at your work,
I look at a picture and say,
oh, they're making history.
Do you look back like that now or is it
still the memory? It's always been, yeah,
that's the strange thing is,
you know, it's, it's being,
it's become so kind of hyperbolized
and you know, the hype,
the hype is pretty over the top.
Um,
but it definitely still feels like,
you know,
something very personal and it always,
it always has, you know, and it,
people ask me to change,
you can know you were a part of
something so important and it's like,
it's kind of absurd. I mean it's,
I don't know, it's just a movie.
It's just an art project.
I think if,
if you set out to make something
important, you're kind of an asshole. So
I certainly try not, I don't think I, you
know, look back on it that way. I'm glad.
I'm glad that it's means
so much to so many people.
I mean that's the kind of the greatest
reaction you could possibly ask for.
There is reward. You did ask for it
with a piece of art is, you know,
beyond people liking it, being moved
by it emotionally. It's really,
like I said,
it's really inspiring to have people be
so honest and open about their feelings.
But,
but no,
it definitely still feels very small to
me and it's hard to communicate that,
you know, when people are being
so kind of hyperbolic about it.
But,
but it is,
it's very small and personal and you know,
it feels strange to be in the
middle of all this. You know,
it'd be in the midst of all these
awards and this is like ultra glamorous
Hollywood stuff and it's like we
don't really belong there and it,
it feels, you know, kind of like crashing
the party, but, but I think, you know,
I think, I think that's straight.
I think hopefully, you know,
a movie like this that is small and is,
you know,
intimate and certainly,
was not made with any intention
of like any of this to be,
you know, to be so recognized and so
kind of connected with and celebrated.
I hope,
you know,
it gives people more courage and
more opportunity to make smaller,
more intimate movies and,
you know, get them out there.
So,
okay,
that'll close our Q and a,
just a reminder that over in the corner,
they will be selling the
book boyhood. Uh, 40% off.
You can't beat that at all.
And I'm sure Matt will be signing them
and I bet Eller would autograph some of
the portraits and my
committing. You aren't. Okay.
All right. It's been a real pleasure
visiting with you. Thank you.
You didn't break out in a sweat. I
did, but I enjoyed it. Thank you.
Thanks.